five on this to talk about this a little
bit there was a move by the defense
attorney eric nelson to say he wanted to
ask for
a mistrial um one he thought that
because the jury had not been
sequestered that that was a problem he
also then pointed to comments that we've
been talking about um
on the on the channel a bit today and
that is the comments by
congresswoman maxine waters in which she
suggested as you saw in that clip maybe
just before we went back to the judge
calling for a confrontation if the
verdict does not turn out the way that
she
wants um so lots happened here we're
also waiting on a press conference we'll
take that to you live that's the
governor of minnesota and other state
officials
to talk about safety in the area as you
can imagine minneapolis
on edge very much so jesse waters could
i start with you in terms of reflections
of the day or maybe even just what we
just heard
especially the judge was probably the
most critical
official that we've heard to talk about
the comments of maxine waters
he called those comments abhorrent and
really admonished her
says she wasn't respecting the balance
of power
and wasn't respecting her oath to uphold
the constitution
but he didn't say that that would
trigger a mistrial and i'm sure defense
will use that on appeal
if that's the case if you look at what
maxine waters said
it's definitely more explicit and more
insightful than what president trump
said
on january 6 but do i think the house is
going to vote to expel her
absolutely not she has a get out of jail
free card and
no one's going to touch a hair on her
head i do think just looking at this
trial
chauvin's going to get convicted of all
three charges the defense was not able
to
move the trial out of the county where
the crime was committed
the prosecution did a great job in jury
selection and the video
is very powerful and it speaks for
itself the murder to
charge dana that doesn't even have to be
intentional this can be unintentional
just the fact that
the knee was on the neck in a felony
manner
caused the death and not even the sole
cause of death just a primary
contributor
to the death the third degree murder
charge again
not the sole contributor just a
dangerous act
the knee on the neck and then the second
degree manslaughter charge
that's just basically negligence and
that's a pretty that's a layup
for the prosecution the only thing there
though
is if they don't do murder two and
murder three
which is basically twelve and a half
years for each one considering chauvin
has no record that manslaughter charge
only carries four years
so if that's the only thing they get
them on the streets are going to go
nuts and the judge is going to be under
a ton of pressure to oversense
that's what i worry about and
maxine waters did not help the situation
there
one of the things and i want to get to
pete because of course he's from
minnesota but let's just get juan in
here quickly
the defense attorney started his closing
argument by reminding the jury
that reasonable doubt is the standard
and that's true across trials all across
america that's the way that's the way
that it is
um the prosecution though they stood up
later in the day and they said use your
common sense believe your eyes
what you saw you saw and then of course
is the video
uh the nine minutes and 29 minute long
video that jesse just referenced one get
your overall take
on today's developments
well remember the what you heard from
the defense was well there's the
possibility that it was the carbon
dioxide from the running car
or there was an angry mob surrounding
the events as they took place dana and
so i think that the
uh defense was trying to you know as a
some said muddy the waters with some of
this and trying to get people
uh away from the idea of as the
prosecution said seeing what they saw
with their eyes and heard with their
ears from the witnesses
um you know to me you know picking up on
what jesse was just talking about i
thought the prosecution's case was very
strong
um but you know it's it's rare that a
policeman gets convicted
in the united states we tend to give
them the benefit of a doubt in these
situations
um but in this case i think if you you
know
you listen to the prosecution you listen
to the defense
you'd have to say that if derek chovin
is not prosecuted here
and found guilty then a policeman can
basically do anything
anything to an american citizen
especially to a black man
without any repercussions because it is
so such an egregious
act as to what maxine waters not jesse
as to maxine waters
clearly what she did was wrong i don't
think we need any more violence here
i don't think i don't think violence is
even going to help the case of people
who are
upset about what happened to george
floyd i think it would in fact
dilute attention on the real problem
which is
police brutality and instead allow
people
to talk about rioting or disruptions in
the streets
so then pete if i can go to you i just
want to read one other thing to you from
eric nelson the
defense attorney he said a reasonable
police officer
officer understands the intensity of the
struggle
and he talked about the fact that
there was this chaos that was going on
in the situation and that george floyd
was resisting
i want to get your take on that but also
we're waiting on this press conference
from the governor of minnesota and local
officials there in minneapolis
given your knowledge of the area give us
a sense of what that might feel like
tonight
well it's it's going to be a tennessee
no doubt uh watching all of it today and
i really did i really get the chance to
do that
i'm going to disagree with my good
friend jesse waters and say that i think
the defense did as
good of a job as possible of attempting
to introduce reasonable doubt
uh and and you know watching the jury
trial today
reaffirmed a lot of of why the american
justice system is a beautiful thing
for all the threats the irresponsible
ones of maxine waters for all the talk
of race
on the outside there wasn't one mention
of race inside the courtroom
except for this sort of odd implicit
bias sermon that the the judge gave at
the end other than that the defense of
the state
stayed away from it and made their best
possible case and
the defense ultimately introduced that
reasonable officer standard that you
mentioned
the defense used body cam footage of the
officers
more often the state used people that
were watching the perspective
ultimately the defense tried to humanize
the decision
decisions of chauvin not that you can
defend what happened for the nine
minutes and 29 seconds
but what about the almost 20 minutes
before that where he's absorbing
information and trying to determine
what the right decision is and they went
minute by minute of the decisions he was
making when he called the emt
that he did not escalate force if he's
talking he's breathing
i'm not justifying it but the defense
did a strong job making a case in front
of a jury
six minority members six white members
it's not the judge that'll make this
call it's not the lawyers that'll make
this call
it is the jury of peers and ultimately
that reaffirms a lot of my faith in the
system
both derek joven got a fair trial today
we'll see what happens
katie i uh let me get your your general
thoughts and again just want to remind
everybody we're waiting for this press
conference that we'll bring to you live
well first if you watched any uh number
of hours of this trial
and especially the closing arguments
today it's very obvious
that what the american people have been
told by the majority of the media in
terms of this being a clear-cut case
is not the case at all it's complicated
it's nuanced there's more video than the
nine minutes that we've been shown
through social media
and through uh news news networks over
the past
six or almost year now but
the reason why the defense asked for a
mistrial as a result of congresswoman
waters
comments is because it's about tainting
the jury because she's intimidating the
jury
if they were to see that given she's in
a crowd that minneapolis has been under
siege
they've seen businesses burned down
people made threats over the weekend you
had one of the use of force
witnesses on behalf of the defense his
former
his former home was actually vandalized
with animal blood
and a pig's head because he's a former
police officer so this intimidation
is an issue especially because the jury
was not sequestered
away from media and in a time where
social media and
these kinds of issues bleed into all of
the other
news items that we're talking about into
culture as well it's pretty astonishing
that the judge did not
require that the jury stay away from
media other than just saying yeah other
than just saying
hey don't turn on the news well not
turning on the news is not the only way
people get
information yeah it's everywhere we'll
see what happens but real quickly real
quickly in terms of what's going to
happen with these officials preparing
for the safety of the cities
it's not just minneapolis and minnesota
minnesota that should be preparing it's
places in california
it's in new york and it will be
interesting to see the differences
between what ron desantis has said about
what they will do with rioters
versus what maybe the mayor of
minneapolis and the governor of
minnesota will say in terms of
consequences
for doing so well let's get something
from